LIKE WHAT GOOD AFTERNOON WE
WILL GETS. WITH OUR ASSEMBLY
BMP SAN SEVEN POINT TWO WHICH-
AGAIN FROM OF THE WHICH TO. NO
OF LOCATION FAR ROOM WE ARE
CURRENTLY IN. FORTY TWO OH TWO.
FOR DIAL IN WITNESSES. THE
NUMBER IS. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN
SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE. FIVE
SEVEN AND THE ACCESS CODE IS.
ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR TWO
ZERO TWO AGAIN THAT PHONE
NUMBER FOR CALLING CALLING IN.
877-692-8957 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS ONE THREE. ONE FIVE
FOUR TWO ZERO TWO TODAY WE ONLY
HAVE ONE BILL THAT WOULD BE
HEARD TODAY ABOUT FORBIDDEN
THAT SAID I JUST WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE AND RECOGNIZE OUR-
PERMANENT VICE CHAIR. OF WHICH
IS ASSEMBLY MEMBER FORCE A
WELCOME SEVEN FOUR. SO LET'S
BEGIN THEN WITH A BILLS IN
ORDER WE ONLY HAVE ONE AND THAT
IS FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE WHICH
IS AB SEVENTEEN TEN. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BOARD- BEFORE WE DO THAT
TOO WE WILL ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
YOU HAD TO DO SO BUT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR NEXT
PRESENTE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
HELLO HERE LOW HERE FLORA. FOR
HERE REGULAR. BLOOM GEN CHEN
HERE CHILL. EGGMAN FONG FONG
HERE GIPSON GIVEN HERE GLORIA
HERE OR HERE GRAYSON. GRAYSON
HERE HOLDEN IRWIN BERMAN HERE
MCCARTY MCCARTY HERE MEDINA
MEDINA HERE MULLIN. OBERNOLTE
I'M NOT HERE TAKING UP TO HERE
WE HAVE A QUORUM. RENDON HERE.
WONDERFUL THANK YOU WE HAVE
ESTABLISHED A CORPSMAN HAS BEEN
IN MOTION AND A SECOND AND WILL
BEGIN AND ALLOW A DOCTOR TO
PRESENT WELCOME. MEMBERS AB
SEVENTY AND- I'M NOT SEVENTY
YEARS. OF OKAY TO GIVE THEM
JUST BONUS HERE FOR FUTURE
THANK YOU VERY MR CHAIRMAN AB
SEVENTEEN TEN WAS AMEND AMENDED
IN THE SENATE TO ALLOW
PHARMACISTS TO ADMINISTER FDA
APPROVED OR AUTHORIZED COVERT
VACCINES. CURRENTLY PHARMACIST
MAY ADMINISTER VACCINES
RECOMMENDED BY THE FEDERAL
ADVISORY COMMITTEE ON
IMMUNIZATION PRACTICES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THE COMMITTEES
VACCINE RECOMMENDATIONS WITH
THE COBRA NINETEEN PANDEMIC AND
THE GOAL OF DUCHESS RAPID
DEVELOPMENT BUT ALSO DEPLOYMENT
OF A VACCINE WILL BE VALUABLE
TO HAVE PHARMACIST ABLE TO
PROVIDE THIS VACCINE SHOULD BE
READY BY THE END OF THIS YEAR.
THE BILL IS NECESSARY BECAUSE
THE PERIOD BETWEEN A VACCINE
BEING APPROVED BY THE FDA
REVIEW BY THE COMMITTEE CAN BE
SIX MONTHS OR MORE. SO THE
VACCINE BE DEVELOPED SHORTLY
I'M SURE WE WOULD ALL AGREE
THAT WIDESPREAD COMMUNITY
AVAILABILITY ACCESS BENEFITS
EVERYONE. FOR THESE REASONS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. ANY MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT AT THIS TIME THAT IS
LOCATED IN HERE IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM SEE ANY MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT C. NINE MISTER OR
MRS OPERATOR- WOULD YOU PLEASE.
OPEN THE LINES IN CASE ANY
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK ON THE SIDE. THANK YOU
MET MISTER CHAIR LATEST IN
GERMAN IF YOU DO WISH TO SPEAK
AT THIS TIME PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON YOUR PHONE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR PHONE.
JUST A MOMENT. AMATEUR WE DO
HAVE SOME PEOPLE ARE QUEUING UP
AT THE MOMENT JUST A MOMENT
PLACE THANK YOU. AMATEUR WE'RE
GOING TO HEAR FROM LINE TO
FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS WHERE THEY GO OVER AND
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
RETAILERS ASSOCIATION AND THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF CHAIN
DRUG STORES AT THE PARK THANK
YOU. WE WILL NOW GO TO LINE.
TWO FIFTY SIX. GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR THAT CAN BOTHER
ABOUT WHAT THE WIDENING GROUP
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
SOCIETY OF HEALTH SYSTEM
PHARMACISTS AND SUPPORT. AND
AGAIN LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO Q.
WISH TO COMMENT. MISTER CHAIR
THERE'S NO ONE ELSE THANK YOU
PLEASE CONTINUE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NUMBER MOVED TO THE
PORTION OF THE MEETING IN.
OPPORTUNITY FOR MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
WITH ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC
HEARING THIS COMMITTEE ROOM
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
SENIOR MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
EITHER VIA ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION ON OUR PHONE LINES.
OPERATOR WOULD YOU KINDLY OPEN
UP AND ASK IF ANY MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME.
COMMITTEE CHAIR. IN GERMAN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. ONE
NINE ZERO. MISTER CHAIR THERE
IS NO WINNING QUEUE AT THIS
TIME PLEASE CONTINUE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AT THIS TIME HE NO QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS DRWOULD YOU WISH TO
CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH THIS
DOESN'T JOINED DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION COMMITTEE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AB SEVENTEEN TEN MOTIONS AND
AMENDMENTS TO BE CONCURRED AND
LOW I KNOW I FLORA. FLOOR AYE
ARAMBULA. REVEAL I BLOOM. CHEN
CHEN AYE CHIU EGGMAN FONG FONG
AYE GIPSON GIPSON AYE GLORIA
GORE AYE GRAYSON GRAYSON AYE
HOLDEN. HOLDEN AYE IRWIN WHEN I
MCCARTY. MCCARTY AYE MEDINA
MEDINA AYE MULLIN OBERNOLTE
OBERNOLTE I CHANGED. THREE
NINE. SURE. CHU I. THIRTY
THIRTEEN ZERO. BILLS OUT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MORE THAT. RIGHT
SECRETARY MISSING ANYBODY. TO
HAVE. OKAY WILL GIVE THE
OVERALL OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL
FIVE MINUTES. WELL. SB FIVE IS
THAT RIGHT YEAH. YEAH WELL.
OKAY YEAH. I DON'T KNOW I. HI
FREE MORNING I GO FOR THE HIGH.
AS A SMALL AND FIFTY DOLLARS.
HI I THINK. IT ALWAYS ENDS UP.
YEAH EXISTENCE. ONE ARE YOU
SURE NOBODY. PLEASE DO. THE
REVENUE TAX.
YEAH.
BOB.
SIX
SEVENTY NINE ZERO THE BILL IS
OUT. INJURED.